- So just make sure you're
in the right session.
This is DAT313.
We're gonna talk about
supercharging app intelligence
on DocumentDB with get
ready, brand new concept
you haven't heard of
before, generative AI.
I know this is new.
We'll walk you through
it, explain what it is.
Raise your hand if you
haven't been to 17 sessions
today about gen AI, right, since lunch.
No, I'm kidding.
So what we're gonna talk about
is a couple different things.
We're gonna go through gen AI.
We're gonna introduce ourselves
in a second, I promise.
We're gonna talk about generative AI,
but from a database perspective.
We wanna look at gen AI from DocumentDB,
from your data stores.
We're gonna talk about the
foundation of these on databases,
on your vector embeddings.
We're gonna go through the
important parts of this.
We're gonna, we're kind
of explain the foundation
of everything we're gonna show you,
and that's those access patterns.
I'm Cody Allen, I'm a
principal solution architect
with DocumentDB.
With me is.
- I'm Doug Bonser, senior
DocumentDB solution architect.
- And what Doug and I do
is we sit down with you.
We talk to customers every single day.
It's our favorite thing to do actually,
talking about DocumentDB.
And in these conversations
we talk about gen AI
and what they're doing with
gen AI, the proof of concepts
that they're doing, the
enterprise applications
they're rolling out.
And we wanna share that with you.
We wanna tell you what we're seeing.
We wanna show you some of the tools,
walk you some demos of
what customers are doing
and what we're doing with gen AI.
We're gonna go through
those access patterns
and we're gonna finish
off with best practices.
It's overwhelming to say the least,
building new generative AI applications.
There's a lot of variables,
a lot of different factors
that go into it.
And we're gonna leave you
with some best practices,
things that you can do to go back
and start building these applications.
With that said, let's go through
a background of what gen AI is.
I'm kidding.
You know what gen AI is already.
What's interesting is
there was a McKinsey study
that said that gen AI is gonna add
between 2.6 and $4.4 trillion
of global economy annually.
That's nuts.
I can't even fathom that types of number.
But really what this is
saying is that gen AI apps
are becoming an enterprise initiative.
Everybody's talking about it.
Who here works for a company
that is not talking about gen AI?
Yeah, exactly.
Everybody's focusing on this.
Finding what they can do
because it's disruptive, right?
There's this massive amount of models
that are available both on the cloud
and that you can run locally.
We'll show some of that.
But the lifeblood of all of
these gen AI applications
is data, secure data,
enrich data, your data.
That's where it all starts.
And that's the most important thing.
Doug and I were up here
last year talking to you
about generative AI on Amazon DocumentDB,
going really deep on some vector indexes
and how you utilize those.
And the thing that we told
you then was that your data
is a differentiator, and guess what?
Nothing has changed.
Your data is still the differentiator.
That's what makes these
gen AI applications
that are gonna be unique to your business.
Now, generative AI applications are seen
as a new application type that sits
on top of your existing data foundation.
That means that you wanna
plug into your existing data
sources, your data lakes,
your data warehouses,
your external or hybrid data source,
your document data stores, right,
in order to build these applications.
Now, customers have
told us they don't want
to create new data architectures
for what is basically
a new application set.
They want to take advantage of the systems
that they already have, the
systems are already using
in production environments.
They want to leverage their
existing architectures
to create these new gen AI workflows.
And they want these new gen AI workflows
and the applications to
follow their enterprise rules
that they've already established.
Now, keeping vectors as close as possible
to that underlying data store
is really gonna simplify
this architecture.
It's gonna minimize the data movement,
the ETL process that you have to do,
it's gonna improve performance
because has less places to stop.
It even has the advantage of
decreasing licensing costs
by introducing new applications.
And speaking of that, when you
start adding these new type
of applications layers, guess what?
You have to learn new APIs,
you have to learn new SDKs.
You have this overhead of
this new programming language
in order to implement these.
But once you have a vector store on top
of an existing database,
you leverage that knowledge
that you already have.
So for example, if your
organization's familiar with
and you store your data in Redis,
well, MemoryDB's vector
functionality would be a good fit.
This goes with Aurora, this goes with RDS
and OpenSearch and Neptune Analytics.
And guess what?
The reason you're here, Amazon DocumentDB.
Generally this allows
you to avoid introducing
a new database component just to be able
to build an AI application.
And you get that confidence knowing
that your existing data structures
are already proven in production.
They already meet your
security requirements.
availability, your storage,
and your compute requirements
by building on top of that.
With that being said, let's
go to that first piece
I was telling you about,
that foundational piece
of vector embeddings.
This is the key component
of vectors on databases.
What is a vector embedding?
Well, it's just a numerical
representation of your text,
even your videos and your photos.
But for the sake of
DocumentDB of your text.
We all can look at what's on
the left and understand that.
We can read those words
and understand the context,
but computers can't.
So what we have to do is we
have to turn it into numbers.
Machines understand numbers,
and we have to turn
that text into numbers.
What this does is it allows
these machines to understand
context in the way
that we understand context.
Words have different meanings
when they're close to other words,
when we ask questions in a certain cadence
or a certain pattern, it
might change the meaning
and therefore change the
results that we get back, right?
It's not a binary search
where I'm just searching
for a name and address and email address.
We're looking for context.
That natural query language.
Now like I said, Doug and I,
we talk to customers all the time
and what we see customers doing
is building these gen AI POCs
and rolling things into production.
But really their goal in doing this
is to improve their customer experience.
They want to improve their
employee productivity.
We see this a lot internally at AWS.
They wanna create brand new content
or they even want to improve
their business operations.
This is across every
business that we talk to,
whether it's financial or engineering
or customer support or sales or marketing.
Customers are running these pilot programs
just to try it out, see what they can do.
They're experimenting with gen AI.
We have very strategic customers
that are building chatbots.
They're doing virtual assistance,
they're doing conversational search
and natural query language
and code generation.
Man, I used to be a terrible
programmer before gen AI.
Now I'm a terrible programmer with gen AI,
but gen AI fixes it for me.
It's wonderful.
I'm amazing, I believe.
I don't think so.
Let's talk about these access patterns.
What are some things that
you can do with this?
Well, the first thing we're
gonna look at is building a tool
that helps us with DocumentDB
using some of our gen AI tools.
We built this Amazon Bedrock-powered
DocumentDB TSQL plugin
for Mongo shell.
Whew, that rolls off the tongue.
It's like 72 lines long.
Clearly I'm not in marketing.
(audience laughs)
Who here is a relational database person?
Either DBA or that's what you know, right?
Me too.
SQL Server, Oracle, MySQL, Postgres.
That's my bread and butter, right?
I look at this minus the
flickering lines there.
I look at this and this
is home to me, right?
This is a warm cup of coffee
on a nice cold day and a nook, right?
Like that makes sense.
Holy cow.
That no longer makes sense.
Hey, it makes sense again.
Select star from table.
Join to this other table where
field equals field, right?
So imagine when I started
my MongoDB journey,
my DocumentDB journey and I had to learn
MongoDB query language, MQL and that bread
and butter nice cup of coffee became this.
Yes, exactly.
It just got all skewed, right?
Doesn't make sense to me anymore.
It's I have to do the lookup,
what the heck's the dollar lookup.
I have to do this dollar project.
I'm not a project manager.
Why do I have to care about project?
And it didn't get any easier
when I had to do update statements.
Again, it's home.
I get this, it feels good.
Like even this far gone
from it, it feels good.
And then I had to go do something
like this on MQL, right?
I have to do that dollar
lookup again for each.
I have to do a function to update this.
Like my simple lizard brain,
my relational brain didn't get this.
So we created this tool that translates
these TSQL commands
into DocumentDB commands
within the Mongo shell environment.
And they're set up to automatically handle
all the supported APIs, operators
and data types in DocumentDB.
And guess what?
We actually made two versions.
We have one that reaches out to Bedrock
and we have one that you can customize
the prompt to the LLM
for that uses Ollama.
So you can actually use
this locally on your machine
if you don't wanna reach out to Bedrock.
(audience chattering)
Dramatic pause.
Let's go into a demo.
Alright, so this is available
out in our GitHub repository
and we have our two
different packages here.
And we're gonna start off by
looking at our Ollama plugin.
We go in that directory
and we're gonna run
our shell script to set this up.
And what this is gonna do is gonna install
all of our dependencies
and it's gonna download
an Ollama LLM for us.
And we'll see that in just one second.
It handles compatibility
using our compatibility tool
to reference what operators it should use
in these Mongo shell
commands against DocumentDB.
And once we do that, we can
see that it's installed.
The Code Llama 7B library.
Now it's a very large library, 3.8 gigs.
It takes a while.
It's not as fast in the real
world as it is the demo,
but that allows us to make
all these calls locally.
We don't have to reach out to Bedrock
or out to the internet at all.
We can see that it was installed.
We had that Ollama-powered
plugin and we just,
and within Mongo shell
we use this TSQL wrapper
to do that query.
So let's go ahead and launch Mongo shell.
It's gonna call on that JS file
that tells us to use it, that it's loaded.
We have a couple name
spaces for this demo.
We have some customers,
some orders, some products,
about a hundred documents
in the customers and orders.
We have a products table that combines
the customers and orders together.
That nasty dollar lookup thing
we were looking at before.
And what we'll do is we'll
run this, this wrapper,
this TSQL wrapper.
And we're gonna do a TSQL
select star from table
where field equals value, right?
Simple, makes sense.
Auto execute false at the end.
That just means that
don't actually run that,
just translate it for me.
So we can see it's review mode.
The commands are not executed
and there is the MQL.
So we're just gonna copy
that, paste that in.
And guess what?
There's no missing quotes,
missing curly brackets.
It just works.
That would've taken me three tries.
It's like plugging in the USB port.
I always get it the third time.
We're gonna make it a little more complex.
We're gonna do select multiple fields
instead of select star.
We're gonna add an extra
wear clause to this
and we're gonna say, Hey,
translate this for me,
all within the Mongo shell environment,
again using Ollama locally.
And here we have all these extra ones
and curly brackets and quotes.
We're gonna copy that.
Hopefully the syntax is correct.
Guess what?
It's a recorded demo, so it's gonna work.
And we have our value there.
Let's take it a little bit further.
So we did select star,
we did select fields.
Let's do a select count from this table.
Same criteria, same filter criteria.
We're not gonna execute it,
we just want it to translate.
And when we run this, we don't
get the find operator back.
We get an aggregation.
Oh man, this would've
taken me like 30 minutes
to mistype every single time.
But now I can just copy that,
paste that in and I get my results. 75.
It did a dollar match with a dollar count.
Like I said, you can customize
the LLM with this tool.
So what we're gonna do is instead of using
that Code Llama 3B or LLM,
we're gonna use that 13B,
about twice the size,
7.4 gigs versus that four.
Again, the trade off here is
you use a lot of space locally,
but you're doing it locally.
Again, demo, this is preloaded.
Might take you a minute to
download that on your machine.
We need to go update our JSON file
that Mongo shell is calling on.
So tell it, instead of using
that Code Llama 7B library,
let's switch over to the Code Llama 13B.
Once we change that, the
cool thing is we don't have
to recompile it anything, right?
This is just a flat file within JS,
and when we launch Mongo shell,
it's gonna be referencing
this new library for us.
So we'll launch Mongo shell.
We will go back into that
demo name space again,
the same place we were before.
You can see nothing's changed here.
We're still using the Ollama.
And we will run the exact
same query we just ran.
That select count IDs from
table with a two wear clauses.
Remember we had a dollar match
and we had a dollar count,
slightly different.
Dollar match, dollar ad fields,
dollar match, dollar count.
But when we run that,
we get the same results.
We still get those 75 results back.
So customize that LLM.
Well, let's switch over.
That was the local version.
Let's switch over to the Bedrock version.
And just like before, we're
gonna run our shell script
to install the dependencies on this.
And this one's gonna go a lot faster
because you're not
installing any local LLM.
It's gonna reach out to Bedrock.
When we run this exact
same process as before,
it's gonna ask us where is
that compatibility tool file.
So it can tell us, give us recommendations
based on supported APIs.
We plug that in, it very quickly
installs everything else.
Now, our next steps
are slightly different.
The first thing we have
to do is run AWS configure
because we are making
calls to Bedrock with this
and we have to have
credentials to do that.
That second item, ensure you have access.
You don't have to do that anymore.
About two, three weeks ago we changed that
and you have access to
all models by default.
So it's old already.
We need to update that.
But you can see it's
using Claude 3 for this.
The interaction is exactly the same.
We have a TSQL wrapper.
So we will go back into Mongo shell
and we can see when we connect
that we are now using the
Bedrock-powered plugin.
We're gonna go into the same name space.
We'll run that same query,
the count ID from table
with these two where clauses.
Now we don't have an aggregate.
We have a count document,
slightly different.
So you can see we're
getting slightly different
results from each of these.
But we have the same number of queries.
What's cool about this?
Oh, I forgot about this one.
So this one you can see we got results.
We left that auto execute false off of it.
So when you leave that off of it,
not only is it gonna
give you the translation,
it's gonna give you the result as well.
This is, it's pretty
powerful For somebody like me
who cannot write a MQL statement
correctly the first 12 times.
It saves me a lot of times.
But what this can get
pretty gnarly, right?
We can put some pretty big
TSQL statements in here
and it'll translate it for us.
So for example, we have this, select star
with a bunch of wheres and
and statements in an order by,
and there we go.
It turns that into a find,
it has some regex searches for us,
has some dollar endless for us.
It has some sort criteria.
It takes care of all of this for us.
So very quickly, instead of Cody crying
and being upset and yelling
at the dogs and children
for not knowing what he's doing,
very quickly we have
the results back there.
So this is really an example
of how you can use these
gen AI tools with DocumentDB
to improve your developer
experience, right?
Make things easier and more productive
for those internal teams.
Next thing we're gonna talk
about are RAG architectures.
Again, dramatic pause
'cause I'm losing my voice.
Now, earlier I told you
that there is a key element
that is the differentiator
for these new gen AI apps.
That key differentiator
is your data, right?
Your data is what makes
gen AI applications
that are unique to your business.
Everybody here has access
to the exact same foundational models.
Just like we saw, you
can get Llama models,
you can get Bedrock models, right?
But only the folks here
that are using their data
to build Gen AI apps are
gonna be creating real value,
that are gonna be creating
something that you can build on
that is gonna improve
your customer's experience
and your employee's experience, right?
Your data is the differentiator
between just generic gen AI app,
like something like ChatGPT and something
that knows your business and
your customers extremely well.
But the good thing is you don't have
to build your own model.
We have some customers that have three,
four decades of documents.
They have billions of documents
that they can refer back to
and they can hire data
scientists, create LLMs.
You don't have to do that, right?
You can use your organizational data
to fine tune these foundational
models through this process
called retrieval augmented
generation or RAG.
And to get very, very technical with you,
what does that mean?
You fetch the relevant information,
you add that to your context
and you generate a response.
Whew.
That's some level 400 stuff.
I'll try to keep it down from
there, folks. I apologize.
Give you an example.
Let's say that you have
this online shoe store
and you want to help out
with an interactive agent.
For example, they say,
can I return my shoes?
I wanna get a refund.
This is where your operational
data store comes in.
So the agent is gonna do a fact lookup
against your database
that has your inventory
or your database that holds
that order information
to get the relevant details.
Then it's gonna do a
vector similarity search
against your collection that
holds your policy documents.
Maybe there's a fee that you charge
if they've ordered it
more than 30 days ago
or maybe they get a free upgrade
if it's within seven days,
whatever it is, right?
You're doing a similarity
search against your data store
as that knowledge repository to be able
to make a decision to replace their shoe.
That's high level.
Let's look at the back end.
Let's look at the architecture
and kind of walk through that.
So number one, that user
is gonna ask the question.
You're gonna have a
prompt that handles that,
but this is where there
the interaction starts.
Next, there is going to be a repository
to hold their conversation history.
A lot of times that conversation
was part of an ongoing conversation.
You have to take the kids
to lacrosse practice.
You have to go cook dinner
or there, whatever, right?
You get distracted, you come back.
You want to hold onto that.
Next, the application needs a query
for your situational data
and that's gonna be outta your data store.
That's what we were talking about earlier,
like the inventory, the order status.
Application's gonna tokenize
that original question
using an LLM to generate
the question embedding.
With that, it's gonna perform
that similarity search
and the vector data store
that's gonna use some kind of algorithm.
Approximate nearest neighbor.
We'll see that later.
Then it's gonna synthesize all of that
into an engineered prompt to send back
to the LLM to get a response.
We had to go update that
conversation again, and guess what?
We end by returning response.
It's kind of the data flow
that we go through there.
Now, this is where DocumentDB comes in.
So with its support of vector
search through vector indexes,
this is gonna run all your vector search
and your data source search are gonna run
against the same repository
because DocumentDB
is your operational data store.
And on top of that, even
though conversation history's
up there by itself, all by its lonesome,
that can sit in DocumentDB.
You just severely decrease the complexity
of that architecture with that support
of vector indexes on Amazon DocumentDB.
Let's go into a demo.
Let's take a look at this one.
So here have a black screen.
It's very nice.
There we go.
Here, what we're gonna do is
create a DocumentDB chatbot,
hopefully.
First thing we gotta do
is install some libraries.
So the two big libraries we're gonna use
is that Gradio, and that's
just for interaction with it
just for the demo and LangChain.
LangChain is what we're gonna
use to create our vectors
that are gonna go into Amazon DocumentDB.
Once we have those established, we have
to set up some variables
for the vector itself.
We have to say how many
embeddings we need.
We have to set some
parameters for the index
that we'll create in just one second.
We're gonna touch on those
values a little bit later.
We won't read too much
into it at this point.
Then we have to establish the index
that we're gonna create
on Amazon DocumentDB.
Here we're gonna create an HNSW index
with cosine similarity
and we're gonna pass
in some of those values
that we established earlier.
Once we have that
established, we can go ahead
and create our Mongo client connection
to our DocumentDB database.
This is using Pi Mongo, MongoDB API.
We're just setting our
pool size, our timeouts.
Then we have to chunk up our data.
We have to put our data into
DocumentDB with the vectors.
And so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna chunk our data
into thousand characters with
200 characters of overlap
'cause we want to keep the meaning.
We don't wanna lose the meaning.
What are the data?
What's the data that we're
going to be processing?
Well, we have the entire 1500 page
developer guide of DocumentDB.
We have our data modeling guide and PDF
and that's what we're
using Lang Chain for.
We're gonna break those apart
into thousand character chunks
with 200 characters of overlap
and then create an embedding off those.
On top of that, we're gonna go parse
every single DocumentDB
blog that's out there
and we're gonna grab all
that information as well
and put that into
thousand character chunks.
Once we have all that
and we're gonna take it
and we're going to feed
that through our, oh yeah,
we're also gonna get the
pricing page and the FAQ page
and the features page, right?
Think of this as your operational data.
Now all this is public,
but for the sake of a demo,
imagine this is your internal information.
We're gonna pass that through
that Titan Text Embedding v2 model
in order to create those embeddings.
We're gonna keep the
original text document,
the thousand characters.
We're gonna keep the vector
content, all those numbers
of those characters, and
we're gonna have metadata.
Where did this come from?
What page is it from?
Things like that.
We'll look at it in just one second.
Once we have all that, we'll
feed that through that model.
It'll chunk it up, it'll
go through the PDFs,
it'll go through the blogs.
It will store all of
that within DocumentDB
and create that index for us
so we can start searching it.
Now, this is our prompt.
So here we're telling that this chat agent
what it's gonna do.
Hey, you are a Q&A assistant
specializing in DocumentDB.
These are the rules, right?
You have to identify technical detail.
You have to ensure the answer is accurate.
We have to tell it.
Dear Lord, that's annoying.
Be clear, be concise.
This one and pause here.
This one's hilarious to me.
Be friendly and helpful.
I want somebody to take this and put,
be unfriendly and unhelpful
and gimme the results.
Like give my contact information,
change that and send me the results
'cause I really wanna go
back and do this myself.
Like what happens if you tell it?
Will it actually like gimme wrong answers?
That'd be fantastic.
Anyway, so that's part of the prompt.
We even give examples,
like here's some examples
of how you could respond.
Like we're just giving the
template of how you should react
to the person that you're talking to.
Once you have all that, we're
setting some thresholds about
how precise we want our answers to be.
The score threshold of 0.8.
We want you to be at least 80% accurate
in those responses you get back.
We set our history.
Remember we have the conversation history.
We want you to remember
the past six things
that we talked about, and
here this is just Gradio.
This is just the interface,
which we'll see in a second.
But before we go into Gradio,
let's look at those
documents in DocumentDB.
So we'll go into that collection
that's storing all these
and we're gonna look at some projections.
So we have about 5,400
documents from those PDFs.
All those blogs.
They got parsed into
5400 different documents.
Those documents look like this.
You have your text content,
there's that metadata
that tells you where it came from.
So for example, this one came
from the developer guide PDF.
We will skip a few,
look at a different one.
This one is about vector embeddings
and it came from a, funny enough,
it came from a blog
about vector embeddings.
How topical.
Again, this is a demo prerecorded.
This is all set up.
It's not a coincidence.
Let's look at a full document.
So what I'm doing is I'm just
showing you a couple fields,
but if we look at the entire document
of what these documents look like
when they're in DocumentDB,
we have our text content.
There are those numbers.
They mean nothing to us.
That's what the computer's
using for that vector index.
We have our metadata, the
title where it came from,
the page, the link.
So here we're gonna ask
it a very simple question.
Does DocumentDB offer
serverless instances?
This is simple, right?
I can just read the dev
guide and figure this out,
but hey, I have a chatbot.
It's fun, it's exciting,
it's supposed to be helpful.
Remember, I wanna see what it's
like when it's not helpful.
We can make it a little
bit more complex, right?
We can say, how do I audit
logins in the cluster, right?
I need to know the use that I connected.
I need to know the time and the date
that they connected, right?
Again, this vector
search is gonna come back
and it's going to give
me the exact answer.
It's gonna say, Hey, do this to enable it.
And by the way, when you enable it,
these logs are go to CloudWatch
and these are the fields
in CloudWatch that you're gonna have.
And by the way, if's a query
that you can run in CloudWatch.
If there's something
I'm worse at than MQL,
it's CloudWatch filtering.
And so there you go.
You have that CloudWatch filter there.
Increasing the complexity.
We can ask about indexes.
I need a partial indexes
on my customer collection.
It filters for this address sate of Texas.
Any Texans here?
Yeehaw, I'm glad.
And it's gonna go back.
It's gonna parse that.
It's gonna look through
it again using our data
to augment that LLM and it's
gonna give us the information,
it's gonna tell us how to do that.
You need to put this
partial filtered expression.
What's cool.
It even tells us exactly what it's doing
and the key points about it.
So it's gonna give us
additional information.
Again, this response can be
customized by your prompt.
Here we're gonna say, I
need to join my orders
and customers collection
by my top three customers.
This was that query we saw earlier.
Again, we saw the TSQL tool
that can do something similar.
But here we're doing
it in natural language
to get this answer.
What I like about this one,
it walks us through it.
It walks us through each stage
of that aggregation again.
So my old lizard relational brain
can understand what the heck it's doing.
Well, you're gonna start
off by doing a dollar lookup
and then you're gonna do a dollar unwind.
You're gonna do a group, right?
It uses all that knowledge
base of what we fed it
to give us this answer that's
specific to DocumentDB.
We can get more complex, right?
The next question we're gonna ask.
Whoever's running this demo is terrible.
Come on, hurry up.
Here's a fun one.
We have an e-commerce platform
currently using Postgres
with separate tables for
products, inventories, orders,
shipping, and customer reviews.
And there's multiple variants
and there's categories.
I have a hundred thousand SKUs.
Watch this on YouTube later.
Pause the video if you
wanna read all that.
I'm not gonna go through
it, but we have this.
(audience member sneezes)
Bless you.
We have this very complex
question that we're gonna ask it.
Let's feed that and see what it tells us.
Well, there we go.
Remember one of the documents we fed it
was a schema design
document with DocumentDB.
And it's gonna use that
to come back and tell us
this is what your product collection
should look like, right?
This is what your
product review collection
should look like.
This is what your inventory document,
your orders collection.
Put this in the hands of
your developers, right?
It's going to streamline their interaction
with document to be in document databases.
(audience member sneezes)
Bless you.
We'll ask it another question about
a more complex situation.
We're saying that we
have a gaming platform.
We track player progress and achievements
and we have 15 normalized
tables and a million daily play.
We're feeding an information about
our rate of operations, right?
And it's taking this in consideration.
These are the things I need.
I need real time player leaderboards.
I need cross game achievement tracking.
I need in-game purchase history.
We're giving it all these requirements.
Figure this out for me, right?
And this is why I'm such a good programmer
'cause I have tools like this.
And it does that.
It gives us a schema, it tells
us how to interact with it.
It tells us where to store the data,
the schema to store the data.
How that data's gonna
interact with each other.
It takes, again, all that
information we fed it
to give us a customized
response for DocumentDB.
The last one I wanna show you is one
I think that gets overlooked a lot.
Something that's really powerful.
We work with a lot of
very large enterprises
that work across the globe.
We have companies that
are based in Nebraska
with developers in Spain and London.
We have customers that
are headquartered in Chile
with developers in Argentina and Brazil.
It's multilingual, right?
That's a great thing about this.
So for example, I'm asking
what language is this?
Does anybody know?
Anybody speak this?
- [Audience Member] Portuguese.
- Portuguese
This is saying is DocumentDB
supported in the Sao Paulo region?
And what it's gonna do, it's
gonna translate that for us.
It's gonna go to our
operational data source.
Say yes, DocumentDB is supported
in the Sao Paulo region.
So now if you have
developers across the globe
using multiple languages,
they can interact with a tool
like this in their native
language and it handles that.
It's gonna answer them the
same way it answers your person
in Nebraska and Spain and
England and Chile and Argentina.
You get those same answers.
So for the next excess pattern,
I'm gonna hand this over to Doug.
Are we gonna?
- Yeah, adjust things
Alright, everybody, still hear me?
Alright, thanks, Cody.
Okay, so we're gonna talk
about third access pattern.
Cody talked about the TSQL
plugin for Mongo shell,
talked about RAG architecture.
So now we're gonna talk
about model context protocol
or MCP servers.
How many of you have not heard of MCP?
Okay, a few.
So most folks are familiar
with it, some not so familiar.
So we'll do a little bit
of introduction about MCP
and how this relates to DocumentDB.
But to put it into to context
like with RAG and the TSQL plugin.
Alright, so maybe you know
how to access the data.
You're familiar with querying
data through Mongo APIs,
but you've got data you, you
really need to dive deep into.
So it's like, you know, where do I start?
Alright, I could start
writing a bunch of queries
and things like that,
but I'm gonna take a look
at MCP servers and how
that might help you.
So, sorry about that.
So just a little bit about MCP model
context protocol servers.
So if you're not familiar
with it, good way to think
of MCP is, it's a way to
provide seamless integration
between your agentic AI
components and applications
with existing tools or systems.
At even simpler, it's
just a standardized way
to access capabilities
that you already have.
So, it is a client server architecture.
And like you see in the screen here,
there's a couple components.
There's four main things to be aware of.
So, there's a host, alright,
the host is an application
that coordinates
and manages multiple MCP clients.
Host could be an agentic AI application
that you've developed.
A host may be Visual Studio Code
like with Klein running in it,
which is what you'll see
in the demo, alright?
But the point is there's
a lot of different hosts,
but they host MCP clients.
What MCP clients do is it maintains
a one-to-one relationship
with an MCP server
or a one-to-one connection
with an MCP server.
So your host will understand
that, hey, I need to reach out
to this server for it to take some action.
That'll create a client,
establish that connection,
and now the host is gonna keep track
of all of the different clients
and which servers they're connected to.
So the server is a lightweight program
that exposes some capabilities, right?
Typically not a lot, but it
exposes some capabilities
through a standard interface
through JSON RPC interface.
And then over on the far right
are your existing data sources.
They could be maybe local data,
local sources like databases or files.
It could be remote data sources,
maybe it's a web service or another API.
But the point is MCP
servers can access all kinds
of sources, whether locally or remotely.
So I wanna focus on MCP servers
here just a little bit more.
So MCP servers have three
different kinds of features,
resources, prompts and tools.
So resources, they're
read-only persistent data
that the server can expose to clients.
So think of it maybe as
some files that you have,
some static files.
You wanna be able to expose
it through an MCP server.
You can do that.
You can define a resource
in your MCP server
and now the clients that
are running in the host,
alright, through maybe a
natural language interface,
you can ask it, Hey,
who's the engineering lead
for the mobile app team?
Alright, you have all
of the HR information
in these static files, you've exposed it,
this resource through an MCP server.
Now you can have that kind of interaction
with these static resources.
Resources don't perform
any kind of actions, right?
They're not gonna take any action
on any other resources
or external systems.
They're simply read only.
Second feature of MCP servers are prompts.
So as you see here, they're
predefined instructions,
they're templates that the server provides
to the clients to understand
what tools do you provide?
What capabilities do you provide?
What does the interface look like?
What information do I need to give to you
to take this action?
What information do you give back to me?
And then the tools, these are the things
that will actually do the work.
So they will take some sort of action.
They could read, they
could write, alright,
but again, they're defined by a schema.
So it's well-defined what this tool does,
the interface to the tool.
And really important point on the bottom.
By default execution requires
explicit user approval, right?
Because most likely you don't
want your agentic AI tool
just running off and
doing all kinds of things,
making changes, dropping
tables, changing data, right?
Now, as you'll see in the
demo, you can set things
to auto approve and things like that,
but by default with MCP servers,
you do need to provide explicit approval.
Okay, so, and now let's just focus on
maybe a particular MCP server.
And this is actually what
you'll see in the demo.
It's a maybe a condensed view
of the Amazon DocumentDB MCP server.
And we'll have a QR code
with a link to it at the end.
But as you see here, we have a client
that's running in a host.
That client connects to the MCP server,
the Amazon DocumentDB, MCP server,
which has all of the different
tools that it exposes
and the logic needed to
implement those tools.
So for example, there's a
tool to allow you to connect
to an Amazon DocumentDB cluster.
There's a tool that will allow you to list
all of the databases in the cluster,
list all of the collections
in the databases.
There's a tool that will allow you
to query the data in the database.
Again, the idea is makes it easier for you
to maybe start exploring a
new data set or a database
that maybe you don't
know a whole lot about,
what's in there, how can I use it?
So with that, let's take
a look at this demo here.
So in this demo I'm using
Klein in Visual Studio Code.
So that's my host and I'm connecting
to the AWS DocumentDB MCP server.
And if you see at the very bottom there,
I've got it configured.
I'm using the Claude, Anthropic
Claude 3.7 Sonnet model.
So, oh, I forgot to press play.
Okay, so we're gonna take a look
at the MCP server itself, right?
There's the Amazon DocumentDB MCP server.
In this case it exposes
16 different tools.
I'm not gonna go through all of them,
but for example, you see
one here, a connect tool
to allow you to connect to
an Amazon DocumentDB cluster.
And this has already set to auto approve
'cause I've been using it
and it's okay to connect
to a cluster, it's not
destructive in any way.
But again, they will default
that those are unchecked.
And then you can see a description
of what that tool does.
Here's another tool, a disconnect
tool that will go ahead,
disconnect from the database.
There's a find tool.
This one I don't have auto approved.
Maybe, you know, I'm not comfortable
with letting it run queries
before I take a look at them.
So again, the point is, through your host,
you'll have this option to
approve, auto approve or not.
So now your role, you're a developer
in an e-commerce company and
you're tasked with trying
to analyze some sales trends
from past holiday seasons.
So your first step is, well,
what's in this database, right?
So you can ask through Klein
what collections are in this database.
So through the MCP server,
you can see it's gone out,
taking a look at it, it's
like, okay, I've got addresses,
customers, orders, products, reviews.
This looks like it has the information
I would need to find what I want to.
So I'll just ask it, okay, well,
what are the most popular
products over the past few years
during the holiday season.
So it goes off, starts working.
Now we're running a new tool
that we haven't run before.
So server exposes and analyze schema tool
to take a look at the
documents, what's in there.
I go ahead and auto approve
it because I'm, okay,
we'll let it just do this every time.
So you can see it's going through,
it's checking the orders collection,
the products collection,
customer's collection,
taking a look at what's in there.
And after it goes off and
does this a little bit,
it'll give us some information.
Now, here we go.
Another new tool, an
aggregate tool, right?
So MCP servers smart enough to know
I've gotta now do some
aggregations to figure out,
you know, what are the top products.
So I'm gonna give it approval to do that.
And then we can see here
what it's thinking, alright?
I'm gonna group the orders by state,
then I'm gonna calculate
the total revenue per state,
go ahead and sort those and
again, get the top products
and get the details about those products.
So I go ahead and approve that.
It'll continue through the process.
So you can see it's going
by pretty quick, right?
But you can see what it's doing,
the different aggregations
and some of the information
that's coming back.
So now it's got some of the top products.
So it's trying to do a find
to get the information
about these products,
but again, need to approve it
'cause of the default is
won't run without approval.
So I'm gonna set it to auto approve
so the next time it'll just carry on.
So I was gonna go ahead,
execute that find.
And we see now that it's processing a lot.
And here's a report.
So basically it took all the information
it got from DocumentDB,
ran it through the LLM
to create this report.
So we can see the top
five states by revenue,
the most popular product
in each of these states
based on quantities.
We see Mississippi
likes the immediate tub,
Maine likes the puny sandpaper and so on.
So, we've got all the
information that we need there.
Now, while you were
doing this, you realize,
okay, you're gonna need
to do this every year.
So if you're like me, you'll
forget how you did this.
So I can just say, hey, gimme
some Python code to do this.
So you can ask, ask client to do that.
You can see it's creating the Python code
needed to generate this report.
It's generating quite a bit of code,
but you can see when you
look at it, all of the code
to handle the different steps, alright?
Code to find the states
with the top revenue
and then to find, okay, based on state,
what's the popular products
in that state, right?
And you can see the aggregations
and queries there for our product.
Gimme the product details, right?
So you see all of the
queries and aggregations
that it created to create this report.
It's now available in this code.
Of course you'll review
the code before you run it,
but you've got a really
good solid starting point.
Now, while you were doing this, alright?
Your boss came along and said, Hey, okay,
I know you're working with us,
can you tell us what's gonna
be hot this holiday season?
Alright?
So again, through natural language
you can just ask it, okay,
based on past products,
past performance, past sales,
what is going to be popular
this holiday season, right?
So you see, you know, it's
trying a lot of different things.
Sometimes you'll see things
maybe that don't work,
so it gets an error so it'll
go try something else, right?
But the point is, it'll get to the point
where it'll do the analysis
and now it's creating a report
of, based on the past couple
of years and sales,
this is what's expected
to be popular this holiday season.
So you can see relatively
easily through MCP servers
agentic AI type of solutions.
You can quickly go in, explore
the data, generate code.
Give you good starting
point for your applications.
Okay, so with that, let's talk about
some best practices in the
time that we've got left here.
So this is probably the first,
well, this is the first time
you're seeing these in
these presentations.
But if you're familiar
with vector embeddings
on Amazon DocumentDB, we
support two different types
of vector indexes.
IVFFlat and HNSW.
Alright, so you've got two to choose from.
Which one do I choose, alright?
So, there's some trade offs between them,
but at a high level, you know, IVFFlat,
the indexes are smaller,
they use less memory,
but they require pre-populated data,
so you have to already
have your data set loaded
before you can create your indexes.
And if you do have workload where
that information is being updated
or you're adding more information,
you will need to rebuild those indexes.
HNSW, on the other hand,
slower index build times,
they use more memory, but
there's better accuracy,
lower latency and you don't need
to rebuild those as your data changes.
So again, which one do you choose?
Well, it's gonna depend
on your requirements,
but typically HNSW is probably
a good place to start.
And to sum it up, IVFFlat, if
you need the fastest indexing,
IVFFlat's a good option for that.
If you want something easy
to manage better performance,
better recall, HNSW.
Just a little bit to give some information
about index build times
or index creation times.
There is some pretty
significant differences, right?
So if you're gonna be building indexes,
creating indexes a lot, right?
This could factor into that.
But this particular test
was run on an 8XL instance.
And what you see here is the
number of embeddings, right?
Remember Cody showed you
the human readable text
and then the arrays and
numbers, those embeddings.
And so we've got one, two, three,
four, five, six embeddings.
The green bar is IVFFlat,
the other bar is HNSW.
So you see, like we said on
the other slide, IVFFlat,
those build times are much lower
in terms of seconds, right,
compared to the HNSW.
So, the scale here is in seconds.
So that's good representation visual
for the difference in build times
between the two index types.
Now HNSW, remember IVFFlat, you
can only build those indexes
on pre-existing data.
So that's your only option.
But those index build
times are pretty quick.
HNSW, you do have options.
You can create the index first
and it will be built as you load the data
or you can also create it after.
But what you see here,
that low purple line
is if you create the index first,
those indexes are gonna
build much faster, right?
Because you're adding the data,
you're updating the indexes.
If you're building it after the fact,
it's gonna take longer.
And honestly it's the
same as recommendations
with any index you create on DocumentDB.
If you can, create it
before you load your data
because you're gonna be able
to update that much faster
than you can if you're trying
to build it after the fact.
Okay, so a couple decision
points IVFFlat versus HNSW.
I need exact nearest neighbor search
or a hundred percent recall,
meaning I need to find the exact match.
Don't use vector indexes, right?
Just use a normal index for
that 'cause you're basically
just doing a point look
up in a quality match.
If you want the fastest indexing, IVFFlat.
Easiest management,
frequent updates, HNSW.
Higher performance, recall rates, HNSW.
So yeah, this is a good
slide to take a picture of
if you want, or like Cody said,
pause the video when it's out on YouTube.
Vector embeddings take up
space in your documents, right?
I mean this is great.
We can add these vector embeddings,
but there is a finite
amount of, finite, sorry,
there is a limit to the size of documents
in DocumentDB, right?
It is 16 megabytes.
So you know, if you've
got a lot of embeddings
and a lot of metadata, you know,
hopefully you're still
not near the 16 megabytes.
But the point is there is a limit,
so you do wanna keep in
mind the impact on the size
of your documents for
these vector embeddings.
So pretty, pretty simple formula.
You see on the top right here,
the key length plus one
plus dimensions times 13.
So the key length is
in this case embedding.
So key length plus one
plus dimensions times 13
in what you've got with
the 13 is four bytes
for an in 32 value, eight
bytes for the element length.
So for each item in that array,
we store it in eight bytes.
And then there's a one byte terminator.
Sorry, there's this one four byte value
sort of at the beginning.
And then each element, eight
bytes, one byte terminator.
All that together gives
you the size of that.
Or if you just look at
the chart, you can see
how a hundred dimensions, it's about 1.3k.
A thousand, it's about 10 times
as much as you can imagine.
So again, just something to keep in mind.
Yeah, it's great to
have a lot of embeddings
in your vectors, get better matches,
but they're gonna take up more space.
So there's a lot of things
to think about, right?
Which vector index type to use,
all of the different settings
on those, how many embeddings,
number of connections and so on.
But a better way to think
about this is take a step back,
you know, what are your
requirements, alright?
How many queries per second
do you need to support?
Alright, what's your query latency?
Does this thing need to run in a second,
less than a second, 30 seconds?
Alright, what's your recall rate?
Does it always have to be an exact match?
Again, vector index is
probably not way to go.
You know, do you need
maybe 90% recall rate
or is 50% good enough?
Again, depending on the answers to those,
it's going to influence
which vector index you use,
IVFFlat or HNSW.
Ingestion time, right?
Again, IVFFlat, the index builds
are really fast on existing data.
So if ingestion time, low
ingestion time is a priority,
maybe you wanna go with IVFFlat
and index build time as well.
So these are the things better to think,
kind of flip it around, think about
what your requirements are
and work into what your index
type and your settings are.
Work into it that way.
Alright, so just a
couple more slides here.
Some tests on query performance, right,
on the different types of indexes.
So this is IVFFlat indexes,
IVFFlat index, excuse me.
What we're showing here
is along the bottom,
the 20, 40, 80, 400, 600,
are the number of probes,
are the number of lists to search.
So an analogy to think
of maybe with IVFFlat,
you've got people live in
apartment buildings, right?
And there's a finite number
of apartment buildings,
let's say 20 apartment
buildings, more people,
there's just gonna be more people
in each apartment building.
So that apartment building
is like that list, right?
So you've got 20 groupings of embeddings,
40 groupings of embeddings, 80 and so on.
Alright, so that's
across the bottom there.
So what you see now on
the queries per second,
certainly the fewer
groupings, the fewer probes,
the faster those queries are
because there's less to search,
but our recall is lower.
It's about 85%.
As you increase the number of probes
or the number of of groups,
the queries per second go down,
but the recall goes up.
But as you see once, in this case,
once you get to about 400,
it's kind of the point
of diminishing returns.
Yes, you can go to 600, get
a little bit better recall,
but you're getting fewer
queries per second.
So again, just keep in mind,
you don't need to always go
to the maximum and that's gonna
vary based on your data set,
based on your embeddings.
But just realize, you
know, there's a point
where you probably don't
really need to go any further.
Same thing with HNSW,
different terms in this.
In HNSW, they call it EF search.
So this is the list size
when you're querying, right,
how many, how many items
are you trying to look at?
And then you see at the
top some information
about the index there.
But similar idea, not to go
into all the details too much,
but again, the smaller the
lists that you're considering,
the higher the queries per second
and you can see much
higher queries per second.
Now we're in the thousands of
queries per second with HNSW.
They're more performant.
But you know, the recall, you
know, maybe that's good enough
for your use case, maybe not.
Well, crank up the EF search.
But again, you get to a point
where you get close to one,
no matter how much further
you go up with the EF search,
it doesn't really go up much,
but your queries per second go down.
So way to sum it up, you know, just test,
get the right value
where it's close enough
to what you need and go with that.
Don't always just max it out
because it's not necessary.
Alright, so best way to
sum all of this up, right?
A lot of information.
You've seen a lot.
You've seen three demos.
Yeah, I've talked about
different types of indexes
and all of these things.
The best way to sum this
up, the first point there,
commit to experimentation early, right?
Just start using these
things if you haven't, right?
If you haven't already started
using this, start using it.
See what it can do, get familiar with it.
I know myself, I didn't know
anything about MCP servers
and when I started using it,
I'm like, holy cow, this
is amazing. I love it.
So, you know, work with it.
The more you use it, the
more you're going to find,
you know, use cases for
it ways to solve problems.
So, you know, start
playing with it, right?
Start using it.
To the second point there, right?
You may find new ways of working,
maybe new ways of developing,
new ways of solving problems
with these technologies, right?
But at the end of the day, what the main,
one of the main takeaways here
is this is why vector support
on DocumentDB is so important.
Like Cody said, alright, your
data is the differentiator.
We're allowing you now to
store these vector embeddings
with your data in DocumentDB.
You've got everything you
need right there to allow you
to do all of these things that
we've showed you here today.
So if you wanna take a
picture of that real quick.
So there's QR codes that'll take you
to the Amazon DocumentDB MCP server
and the Mongo shell TSQL plugin.
And I realized my mistake here,
I forgot to emphasize something
very important early on.
And what I was supposed
to emphasize early on
is for HNSW indexes is that
you should always create
your indexes before inserting your data
on a new namespace, right?
Very important.
So I don't know if you've
been to one of these sessions
like this, but if you go to the booth
and maybe you tell somebody that,
hey, always create your indexes on
before inserting your data
in your name spaces, alright?
You might be able to get a hoodie.
Alright.
So with that, thank you all very much
for your time, for your attention.
Please give us feedback, alright?
(audience applauds and cheers)
Just, you know, be candid.
We want candid feedback, we
want to make these better.
You know, we think we're telling people
what they want to hear.
Maybe it's not, right?
Maybe we told you stuff that
you don't find that helpful.
Let us know so we can adjust
and continue to make these things better.
So we do take a look at the feedback
and we do take it seriously.
So please, please provide that.
But again, thank you very much.
On behalf of Cody, enjoy
the rest of your stay here
at re:Invent and have a good evening.
(audience applauds)